your kids get to see it beforehand
they'll see it tonight oh they'll see
tonight yeah yeah they'll say I'm gonna
see it with them for the first time oh
you haven't seen me know I haven't seen
oh man can I come with you guys come on
it'll be a lot of people there well
there was more there than mark was
counting on mark accidentally
live-streamed inside the theater on
instagram it was only audio after about
10 minutes mark realized what was going
on and shut it down and he joked about
it
at the Australian premiere hey Marvel
fans I'm here at the Thorpe for our
three premiere and it's kicking ass I'm
having the best time and wish you were
here
if I had my Instagram live on I could
let you watch the other half of the
movie
this far into playing the Hulk dear kids
ever give you tips unlike with the hawk
should be doing or what he shouldn't be
doing like how to play him no but I just
steal from them because they're like
little Hulk's a frico they're like I
don't wanna do yeah I been stealing from
them for years they should get a they
should get a cut of it they do get a
kind of it's got a bit by the way I won
easily since I'm right now you guys get
to play against one of the the meanest
villains one of the best villains hella
as played by Cate Blanchet in this one
why is she perfect why is she perfect
this I knew before you'll clean because
she's beautiful chilling seductive and
and dark yeah she's like Shiva man she's
the creator and the destroyer she's
right and who wouldn't wear that I know
that things its own character you know
in my seat I would love for someone else
to rule but it can't be you you're just
now you have hung out with Thor enough I
think I can do this with you I think I
can ask you this Thor is the Norse god
of thunder so do you think you could
give me your best attempt at some of
these Nordic words Toph will help you
agree blah Heidi crime didn't drive
TOEFL help Google bar hi AG her injury
Nordic swear whatever things I could've
possibly said